Nộ sảy ra với lúc hòa mấy giờ bộ mấy lắm phút sáng ngày 1 mọi thống người theo dưới phương,
sân phản toàn bộ của cuộc sản xuất của Accurate Energy Systems,
công ty của phòng đặt cảnh Nát Sveal khoảng tám mấy kêu mấy,
cảnh sát cho biết vẫn còn quá sớm để sát đẹn có số thương vong,
trong khi lực lượng cố hộ tiếp tục tìm kiểm người mất cách,
không tìm mạnh đầu cho biết có nhất mới chỉ người thương vong.
Ê, bây giờ, có bây giờ, tui lại số mở chân nổ, ATF đã được quy đậm để điều trai ngoan nhận,
dù tương sảy ra sự cố nhỏ năm 2018,
khi nhưng nhằm ấy này chưa tương bể ghê nhận vì phạm ăn toàn nghiêm trọng.
Bù viện này làm dưới lây lâu ngày, vì mức đồ ăn toàn và các thương sử sản xuất vật liệu nổ,
và hả năng giám xác của cửa quang quả lý,
cho bất cảnh Mỹ đang căng tóc sản xuất của bụng cuối phòng và các nền tung nghiệp chế lợp.